programming throwdown episode 99 squashing bugs using ai and machine learning with boris paskalov take it away jason hey. This is a really, really fascinating topic. I think there's been a lot of interest around using AI to sort of help developers. We've all had apps, even like super popular apps like the Uber and the Google app and other apps where they have bugs and they crash and things like that. So even the people who are the best at this have tons of issues. And so it's becoming a really interesting area. And we're so fortunate we have Boris Puskalev, the CEO and co-founder of DeepCode, to kind of sit down and roundtable how we can make software better.
Programming Throwdown 第 99 期：与 Boris Paskalev 一起探讨如何利用人工智能和机器学习消除 Bug。Jason，开始吧。嘿，这是一个非常、非常引人入胜的话题。我认为人们对利用人工智能来辅助开发者产生了浓厚的兴趣。我们都用过各种应用，甚至是像 Uber、Google App 等超级流行的应用，它们也会出现 Bug、崩溃等问题。所以，即使是这个领域最顶尖的人才，也会遇到大量的问题。因此，这正成为一个非常有趣的领域。我们非常荣幸能请到 DeepCode 的首席执行官兼联合创始人 Boris Paskalev，来和我们一起探讨如何让软件变得更好。
So Boris, why don't you kind of start off by telling us, like, a little bit about your background. You know, what was the idea or the inception of DeepCode and, you know, kind of at a high level of what you guys are doing right now. Sounds good. So, welcome, everyone. Thank you for having me. So, my name is Boris Paskalev. I was originally born in Bulgaria. And I did my bachelor's in Mastering Computer Science in Boston and then worked with a number of different companies as a developer. Later on in my life I did an executive MBA so I started moving into project management, program management and many different things in that space. And yeah, and I'm still working in technology,
那么 Boris，不如先向我们介绍一下你的背景。你知道，DeepCode 的想法或起源是什么，以及你们目前在宏观层面上正在做什么。没问题。大家好，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你们的邀请。我叫 Boris Paskalev。我出生在保加利亚。我在波士顿获得了计算机科学学士和硕士学位，之后在多家公司担任开发者。后来，我攻读了高级工商管理硕士（EMBA），开始转向项目管理、项目规划以及该领域内的许多其他工作。是的，我仍然在科技行业工作，
but I'm coding less and less, as you can imagine. So about DeepCode, obviously, the idea is that it started in 2016, and it's a spin-off from ETH Zurich, which is the number one tech university in Europe. I usually call it the MIT of Europe when I make fun with the guys. Nice. But yeah, the idea is that my other two co-founders, Professor Dr. Martin Vechef and Dr. Veselin Raichev,
但正如你所想象的那样，我写代码的时间越来越少了。关于 DeepCode，显然，这个想法始于 2016 年，它是苏黎世联邦理工学院（ETH Zurich）的一个衍生项目，这是欧洲排名第一的科技大学。当我和那里的伙伴们开玩笑时，我通常称它为“欧洲的麻省理工学院”。不错。但确实，我的另外两位联合创始人是 Martin Vechef 教授和 Veselin Raichev 博士，
so they spent about 12 years together researching the topic of learning from big code, so program analysis and how we can really apply powerful machine learning algorithms on top of code. And they've published many, many papers, lots of awards in the space. And after our CTO, Veselin Wright, finished his PhD, pretty much the idea was clear that we have to start that as a new platform that should revolutionize how software development works over time. So that's really the passion behind it. Cool. So let's unpack a lot of that. So you were a software developer, and then at some point you went to a business school. What sort of inspired that? Oh, that's an interesting question.
他们在一起花了大约 12 年时间研究从大数据代码中学习的课题，也就是程序分析，以及我们如何真正将强大的机器学习算法应用到代码之上。他们发表了许多论文，在该领域获得了许多奖项。在我们的首席技术官 Veselin Raichev 完成博士学位后，我们的想法很明确，即必须将其作为一个新的平台启动，以彻底改变软件开发随时间演进的方式。这就是其背后的热情所在。太棒了。让我们深入探讨一下。你曾是一名软件开发者，后来在某个阶段去了商学院。是什么启发了你这样做？哦，这是一个有趣的问题。
I think it's a consequence of many, many events. But slowly, as a software developer, I started kind of project managing the software I was dealing with, kind of delivering it to the end users and kind of working on the end-to-end, trying to actually get specifications from them, understand how we test it, obviously making sure there's less and less bugs, making sure that we fulfill the right requirements. And kind of in my head, slowly,
我认为这是许多事件共同作用的结果。但作为一名软件开发者，我慢慢开始负责管理我所处理的软件，将其交付给最终用户，并进行端到端的开发，尝试从他们那里获取规范，了解我们如何测试它，显然要确保 Bug 越来越少，确保我们满足了正确的需求。在我的脑海中，慢慢地，
I started building this overall picture that it's not just the software, but it's an end-to-end process. So I started project managing some of those, then they started giving me larger projects with more people. And then all of a sudden, the project became project became hey build a software that actually runs this robotized production line and then that this is how I ventured out outside of the software for software space and then eventually I just had projects like can you open our development office in Switzerland and that's how I kind of moved into non-software projects and eventually I said well then I really do do that successfully I need to learn a bit more about that that side of the world and can say that's an executive MBA. Cool that makes sense so you know this is a something I've always wondered is what do you
我开始构建起一个整体的蓝图：这不仅仅是软件，而是一个端到端的流程。所以我开始管理其中一些项目，然后他们开始交给我规模更大、涉及人员更多的项目。突然之间，项目变成了“嘿，构建一个能运行这条机器人生产线的软件”，这就是我如何走出纯软件领域，最终我接手了一些项目，比如“你能帮我们在瑞士开设开发办公室吗”，这就是我如何转向非软件项目，最终我说，好吧，如果我真的想成功做到这一点，我需要更多地了解那个领域，于是就去读了 EMBA。酷，这很有道理。所以，你知道，我一直很好奇，你
think about the idea that that at what level do you not need to have a technical background so for example does a line manager need to be technical? A line engineering manager? Does the director need to be technical? And at what point do you say, okay, this now has transitioned fully into project management, process management from like a business perspective? That is a very polarized topic. I mean, as a techie, I obviously believe that everybody should have technical understanding and background just because this is where you learn basic logic, let's put it that way. Start thinking more like a machine than a person, to put it that way.
认为在什么层面上你不需要具备技术背景？例如，一线经理需要具备技术背景吗？一线工程经理呢？总监需要具备技术背景吗？在什么节点上，你会说，好吧，从商业角度来看，这已经完全过渡到项目管理和流程管理了？这是一个非常两极分化的议题。作为一名技术人员，我显然认为每个人都应该具备技术理解和背景，仅仅因为这是你学习基本逻辑的地方，我们姑且这么说吧。开始像机器一样思考，而不是像人一样思考，姑且这么说。
And I think everybody should have a little bit of that. I mean, clearly, when you're going to the arts, etc., there is quite a big range that you might not need that. But for anything, when you're working in the business world, you need some kind of a technical background, being that pure math that can actually lead into the same way of thinking. But with that said, there's many exceptions. I had many colleagues that didn't actually have any technical background. One of my very first technical manager, brilliant developer, he actually has a PhD in literature, right? So, yeah. So there's plenty of exceptions in the rule. Yeah, totally.
我认为每个人都应该具备一点这方面的能力。显然，当你从事艺术等领域时，可能确实不需要这些。但对于任何在商业世界工作的人来说，你需要某种技术背景，即使是纯数学也能引导出同样的思维方式。但话虽如此，也有很多例外。我有很多同事根本没有任何技术背景。我的第一位技术经理，一位出色的开发者，他实际上拥有文学博士学位，对吧？所以，是的。规则总是有很多例外。是的，完全同意。
And we have a lot of folks listening who maybe they started listening when the show started, I don't know, Patrick, what, eight years ago or something. And they have all sorts of different degrees um and backgrounds and and one of the awesome things about this area is that is that so it's so easy to pick up um you don't need to have a really long apprenticeship um actually i was reading something that if you're a hand doctor it's actually one of the hardest professions to pick up. And so in software you can do it in, you know, I mean it's a craft so you have to develop it like any craft, but you can at least get started quickly regardless of your background.
我们有很多听众，也许他们从节目开始时就开始收听了，我不知道，Patrick，大概八年前还是什么时候。他们拥有各种不同的学位和背景，而这个领域最棒的事情之一就是它非常容易上手，你不需要进行非常漫长的学徒期。实际上，我读到过，如果你是一名手外科医生，这实际上是最难上手的职业之一。而在软件领域，你可以做到，你知道，我的意思是这是一门手艺，所以你必须像对待任何手艺一样去培养它，但无论你的背景如何，你至少可以快速入门。
Yeah, I think we just actually hired a junior software developer that had zero background in software development. Like a couple of years ago he said, hey, I just want to be a developer. And he started picking it up. And I think with modern languages and frameworks, it is getting easier and easier to get into it, which is great. And there's a lot of tools that can help you along the way. Cool.
是的，我想我们最近刚雇佣了一名初级软件开发者，他完全没有软件开发背景。大概几年前他说，嘿，我只想成为一名开发者。然后他就开始学习了。我认为随着现代语言和框架的出现，入门变得越来越容易，这很棒。而且有很多工具可以在这一过程中为你提供帮助。酷。
So let's go into deep code. So you're talking about this person, these two folks who were doing some academic research on code analysis. And one of the things I think that's hard to grasp for a lot of people is how do you do analysis on code, right? I mean, you can imagine, I guess you have to get rid of all the white space, right? But it's this sort of really complicated language. It doesn't have clear parts of speech. So a lot of NLP techniques, it's not obvious how they would work here. And so how does one even begin to sort of programmatically understand a C++ file?
那么让我们进入 DeepCode。你谈到了这两个人，他们正在进行关于代码分析的学术研究。我认为对很多人来说，很难理解的一点是，你如何对代码进行分析，对吧？我的意思是，你可以想象，我想你必须去掉所有的空白字符，对吧？但这是一种非常复杂的语言。它没有明确的词性。所以很多自然语言处理（NLP）技术，它们在这里如何工作并不明显。那么一个人如何开始以编程方式理解一个 C++ 文件呢？
Like how does that actually work? It is a very, very good question. And the short answer is it is very hard. I bet. But you start with extremely good developers. That's the number one thing. I think both of our other co-founders, they're really like, they're language agnostic.
这到底是怎么运作的？这是一个非常、非常好的问题。简短的回答是，这非常困难。我敢肯定。但你从极其优秀的开发者开始。这是第一要素。我认为我们的另外两位联合创始人，他们真的像是语言无关的。
They can literally do anything. They understand the languages inside out. Because the majority of the problem is program analysis. I mean, it's a pretty old type of thing that it's not very sought after today, but it really kind of gives you the core of what it is. So let me just walk you high level to the process of what it is. So first you start with parsers. So for each language there is a parser.
他们几乎可以做任何事情。他们对语言了如指掌。因为问题的大部分在于程序分析。我的意思是，这是一种相当古老的类型，今天不太受追捧，但它确实为你提供了核心内容。所以让我从宏观上带你了解一下这个过程。首先，你从解析器开始。每种语言都有一个解析器。
So we actually use one of the standard parsers, maybe small changes here and there, but that's about it. And then a lot of tools pretty much end up here. They're just minor adjustments because the parser gives you an abstract syntax tree or AST, and then people work on it. But the ASTs are not rich enough. They don't really represent everything that you need in the program,
所以我们实际上使用了标准的解析器之一，可能这里那里做了一些小的改动，但仅此而已。然后很多工具基本上就止步于此了。它们只是做了一些微小的调整，因为解析器为你提供了一个抽象语法树（AST），然后人们就在此基础上工作。但 AST 的信息量不够丰富。它们并没有真正代表程序中你需要的一切，
as you said, very complex. So this is where kind of the magic starts. We actually use proprietary solvers that actually extract every single semantic fact in the program, every single interaction, every single function, every single variable, every single object, and we build the relationship between them in terms of who is calling who, how is it changing, are you casting something to something else etc etc so this actually goes into a graph index that she represents this whole interactions of of the cult and this is
正如你所说，非常复杂。所以这就是魔法开始的地方。我们实际上使用了专有的求解器，它们提取程序中的每一个语义事实、每一次交互、每一个函数、每一个变量、每一个对象，我们构建它们之间的关系，比如谁在调用谁，它是如何变化的，你是否将某物转换成了其他东西等等等等。所以这实际上进入了一个图索引，它代表了代码的全部交互，而这
kind of the key piece right and this graphing this has to be pretty much in a machine learnable format right so then you can apply machine learning on top of it so that's kind of where most of the magic is kind of to create a machine learning representation for code which is pretty much does not exist today or if it exists as you said it's been it's treating the the code as string as text which obviously drops down all the semantic facts that are interesting about coding um and and after you have this machine learning representation, then it's all about speed, efficiency, to learn from every single fix ever made, every single line of code that exists out there,
是关键部分，对吧？这个图索引必须基本上是机器学习可读的格式，对吧？这样你就可以在它之上应用机器学习。所以这就是大部分魔法所在，即为代码创建一种机器学习表示，这在今天基本上是不存在的，或者如果存在，正如你所说，它只是将代码视为字符串、文本，这显然丢失了所有关于编码的有趣的语义事实。嗯，在你拥有这种机器学习表示之后，剩下的就是速度和效率，从曾经做过的每一次修复、现有的每一行代码中学习，
and then apply machine learning algorithms to extract specific facts. This actually brings you to have this knowledge base of everything that has happened, how people can fix different things, are there consensus how to fix them, are there, how people have fixed different things, are there consensus how to fix them, are there people fixing it in totally different ways, then you can actually assign probabilities of what problem is likely to be fixed in a specific way versus in another way.
然后应用机器学习算法来提取特定的事实。这实际上让你拥有了一个涵盖所有已发生事件的知识库，人们如何修复不同的东西，对于修复它们是否有共识，人们是如何修复不同东西的，对于修复它们是否有共识，是否有人以完全不同的方式修复它，然后你实际上可以为特定问题以某种方式修复的可能性分配概率，而不是以另一种方式。
Got it. Okay, so let me see if I can unpack this. So similar to sort of the grammar parsers, if folks listening remember that from grade school, how you would have the sentence, you know, the man went to the supermarket and you'd have to diagram that sentence. And you would separate out the subject and the verb and you'd draw this little graph to represent that sentence. You can do the same thing with code. And then I guess, but that by itself. So can you explain a little bit what has to happen to turn that syntax tree into a machine learnable format?
明白了。好的，让我看看我能否拆解一下。所以类似于语法解析器，如果听众还记得小学学过的内容，你会有一个句子，你知道，“那个人去了超市”，你必须对那个句子进行图解。你会分离出主语和谓语，并画出这个小图来表示那个句子。你可以对代码做同样的事情。然后我想，但这本身……所以你能解释一下，将语法树转换为机器学习可读的格式需要发生什么吗？
So in other words, why couldn't the machines just learn on the syntax tree? What's missing there? So it's missing a lot of the interactions and the depth. For example, you cannot track. For example, you have an object you put it into an array, right, and then you actually get this object out of the array. The abstract syntax tree will not be able to tell you if it's the same object, right? So the idea is that you have to have a much, much, much larger depth and naturally tracking every single thing that happens. Like you need inter-procedural analysis, points-to-analysis,
换句话说，为什么机器不能直接从语法树中学习？缺少了什么？它缺少了很多交互和深度。例如，你无法追踪。例如，你有一个对象，你把它放进一个数组里，对吧，然后你实际上从数组中取出了这个对象。抽象语法树将无法告诉你它是否是同一个对象，对吧？所以想法是，你必须拥有更大、更大、更大的深度，并且自然地追踪发生的每一件事。比如你需要过程间分析、指向分析、
type-state analysis, may-versus-must analysis. So there is a very wide range of different things that abstract syntaxes will not be able to give you. And that's why the type of issues or representation you actually make on them are much more
类型状态分析、可能与必须分析。所以有非常广泛的不同事物是抽象语法树无法提供给你的。这就是为什么你在它们之上所做的议题或表示类型要简单得多。
simplistic. And then if you build rules on top of them, then your accuracy level, it's much lower. So you get lots of false positives. Got it. That makes sense. So similar to, you've talked in the past on type inference and how, well, it probably started way before Haskell, but Haskell, I think, is where it started to become popular. And then you saw Scala with it,
然后如果你在它们之上构建规则，那么你的准确率就会低得多。所以你会得到很多误报。明白了。这很有道理。所以类似于，你过去谈论过类型推断，以及，好吧，它可能在 Haskell 之前很久就开始了，但我认为 Haskell 是它开始流行的地方。然后你看到了 Scala，
and now you have almost every TypeScript has it, Python has it. And so what they're doing is they're looking at the program flow, and they're saying, you know, x equals 3, a equals x, and so therefore a is also an integer. And so they're kind of tracing through. And you're saying that you need to do that kind of tracing through. And you're saying that you need to do that kind of as a pre-processing step to actually look at the runtime flow in addition to the syntax, and all of that goes into some,
现在几乎每种语言都有了，TypeScript 有，Python 也有。所以他们所做的是观察程序流，他们说，你知道，x 等于 3，a 等于 x，因此 a 也是一个整数。所以他们正在进行追踪。而你说你需要进行那种追踪，并且你说你需要将那种追踪作为预处理步骤，除了语法之外还要观察运行时流，所有这些都进入某种，
let's say, connection structure, some type of graph. That is correct. And the key part here is that we're actually doing this statically, right? So we don't have to actually build the code. We don't have to actually, we don't even have to compile it, make sure that it runs. We can actually track this purely by actually understanding the structure.
比方说，连接结构，某种类型的图。这是正确的。这里的关键部分是我们实际上是在静态地做这件事，对吧？所以我们不需要真正构建代码。我们不需要真正，我们甚至不需要编译它，确保它能运行。我们可以通过真正理解结构来纯粹地追踪这一点。
This is where the program analysis come in. Got it. Okay, cool. That makes sense. And then at that point, it's just ingesting as much code as you can, looking at zillions of GitHub pull requests that say, you know, fix array out of bounds error. There's probably, you know, 800,000 of those in GitHub. And so you can kind of look at all of those and see what the common structures are.
这就是程序分析的用武之地。明白了。好的，酷。这很有道理。然后在那一点上，它只是尽可能多地摄取代码，查看 GitHub 上成千上万个写着“修复数组越界错误”的拉取请求。GitHub 上可能有 80 万个这样的请求。所以你可以查看所有这些请求，看看常见的结构是什么。
That is correct, because when you actually convert it to this internal representation that we have, then that becomes purely language agnostic, right? That's kind of the best part. So the only thing that is language specific is the parsing, and then the representation is language agnostic. So we don't care how the developer wrote it. We actually care what it does and how it actually does it.
这是正确的，因为当你真正将其转换为我们拥有的这种内部表示时，它就变得纯粹与语言无关了，对吧？这是最棒的部分。所以唯一与语言相关的是解析，然后表示是与语言无关的。所以我们不在乎开发者是如何编写它的。我们实际上关心它做什么以及它是如何做的。
Got it. Do you look at the variable names, or is that just too much noise? So we actually have metadata that we actually track back to what it is, because that's the idea that when we understand the problem, we can actually point to where it's coming from and what it does. But ultimately, we don't care what the variable name is. It could be anything. Yeah, that makes sense.
明白了。你们会查看变量名吗，还是那只是太多的噪音？我们实际上有元数据，我们会追踪回它是什么，因为这就是想法，当我们理解问题时，我们可以真正指出它来自哪里以及它做了什么。但最终，我们不在乎变量名是什么。它可以是任何东西。是的，这很有道理。
I mean, I can imagine just semantic errors. You say miles equals feet times 10 and say, okay, that's an issue. But I feel like, as you said, it's just too hard. There's just too many different names for things. Yeah, so there is a different tool that we have released and that was during the research years that is delphiscation. It actually tries to predict very accurately what is the best name for each variable
我的意思是，我可以想象只是语义错误。你说“英里等于英尺乘以 10”，然后说，好的，那是一个问题。但我觉得，正如你所说，这太难了。事物的名称太多了。是的，所以我们发布了另一个工具，那是在研究期间发布的，即去混淆（de-obfuscation）。它实际上试图非常准确地预测每个变量的最佳名称，
because you can delphiscate it so you can de-obfuscate it so you can actually make it human readable. Yeah, de-obfuscate it. Yeah, so in that state, we actually have pretty good heuristics based on pretty much machine learning based on how a specific variable is used and what it does
因为你可以混淆它，所以你可以去混淆它，这样你就可以让它变得人类可读。是的，去混淆。是的，在这种状态下，我们实际上有相当好的启发式方法，基于机器学习，基于特定变量是如何使用的以及它做了什么，
and then understand how people name it and then understand what the right name should be. That is super cool. Yeah. Yeah, is that something that people can just try out? Can they just upload a CPP file and see what the Deoptis Gator... I think that was mainly for Java. It's JS nice and
然后理解人们是如何命名它的，然后理解正确的名称应该是什么。这太酷了。是的。是的，这是人们可以尝试的东西吗？他们可以上传一个 CPP 文件并查看去混淆器……我想那主要是针对 Java 的。是 JS Nice 和
nice to predict. Those are the two tools that actually do that. And they're free to use, so anybody can upload anything there and use it. Oh, very cool. You have to check that out. So you said JSNice? JSNice, yes.
Nice to predict。这是两个真正做到这一点的工具。它们可以免费使用，所以任何人都可以上传任何东西到那里并使用它。哦，太酷了。你必须去看看。所以你说 JS Nice？JS Nice，是的。
JSNice. Cool. Yeah, we'll add it to the show notes. So, okay, let's spiral back a bit to the sort of product and market here. So how do folks, you know, in general, how do folks find bugs now? Especially, you know, I mean, we've all found bugs, you know, in our school projects and things like that. But when you're in these enormous software engineering teams, so imagine you're building the Amazon app or something. How do developers go about finding bugs in these sort of monolithic projects? Wow, it really depends. I mean, there's ultimately two major ways. The human way, like when you're using humans to do it, and some kind of automated ways. Human way is obviously a range,
JS Nice。酷。是的，我们会把它加到节目笔记中。所以，好的，让我们回到产品和市场这里。那么人们，你知道，总的来说，人们现在是如何发现 Bug 的？特别是，你知道，我的意思是，我们都在学校项目中发现过 Bug 之类的。但当你身处这些庞大的软件工程团队中时，所以想象你正在构建 Amazon App 之类的东西。开发者是如何在这些单体项目中发现 Bug 的？哇，这真的取决于情况。我的意思是，最终有两种主要方式。人类的方式，就像当你使用人类来做这件事时，以及某种自动化方式。人类的方式显然是一个范围，
like while coding, like yourself, or when you're doing peer programming, you have your counterpart actually say, hey, what the hell is that? So that's standard, right? The peer code reviews, I mean, code reviews are pretty common today. So that's one of them, I think most common ways
比如在编码时，像你自己一样，或者当你进行结对编程时，你的搭档实际上说，嘿，那是什么鬼东西？所以这是标准的，对吧？同行代码审查，我的意思是，代码审查在今天非常普遍。所以这是其中之一，我认为最常见的方式
that people will actually identify issues. And then unit and functional testing that you've built or you're building as you're developing. The more, sometimes I call it old school, but it's really actually pretty popular still today, actual QA testing or QA processes. There's many different ones. Lots of them are still human-based.
人们实际上会识别问题。然后是你构建的或你在开发时正在构建的单元测试和功能测试。更多的时候，我有时称之为老派，但实际上今天仍然非常流行，实际的 QA 测试或 QA 流程。有很多不同的流程。其中许多仍然是基于人类的。
And then the very final one is you're actually customers or users testing it and saying, hey, this broke. What the hell? What should I do with it? So I think this is kind of the range of the human identification of bugs. And there's obviously many automated ways that are actually
然后最后一种是你的实际客户或用户在测试它并说，嘿，这坏了。什么鬼？我该拿它怎么办？所以我认为这就是人类识别 Bug 的范围。显然还有许多自动化方式，它们实际上
coming this way, that using actual static analysis, the automatic test coverage or test generations, then you have the wider range of formal verification or fuzzing, then there's actually some compliance testing that could be happening. So you have some for specific industry, there's a specific set of rules that you have to test for, then they can uncover issues. Obviously, there's dynamic analysis as well. That's pretty big those days. And there's many areas that you can catch things by just simulating the runtime of the program, or actually running it live while the users are performing operations. Yeah, that makes sense. I think as you move along that continuum, you add sort of more and more, I guess, risk or more side effects, right? So if a bug makes it all the way out to the end user, it can be totally catastrophic.
正在以这种方式到来，使用实际的静态分析、自动测试覆盖率或测试生成，然后你有更广泛的形式化验证或模糊测试，然后实际上有一些可能正在发生的合规性测试。所以你有一些针对特定行业的，有一套特定的规则你必须测试，然后它们可以揭示问题。显然，也有动态分析。这些天这非常重要。有很多领域你可以通过仅仅模拟程序的运行时，或者在用户执行操作时实际实时运行它来捕捉问题。是的，这很有道理。我认为当你沿着那个连续体移动时，你增加了越来越多的，我猜是风险或更多的副作用，对吧？所以如果一个 Bug 一直传到最终用户那里，它可能是完全灾难性的。
Like you break the login page for your app. You might never recover from that. Actually, I know companies who, like small companies that broke the login page and literally never recovered. And you go all the way to the other end of the spectrum where there's a static analysis tool so that before you've even hit save on the file, you know that there's an issue. And so that's obviously anything you can catch there adds huge value to your time and to de-risking the project.
比如你弄坏了应用的登录页面。你可能永远无法从中恢复。实际上，我知道一些公司，比如小公司弄坏了登录页面，真的就再也没有恢复过来。而你一直走到光谱的另一端，那里有静态分析工具，所以甚至在你点击文件保存之前，你就知道有一个问题。所以显然任何你能在那里捕捉到的东西都会为你的时间增加巨大的价值，并降低项目的风险。
Correct. So ultimately, the belief is yes, the earlier you catch it in the development cycle, it is much cheaper. I think there is an exponential growth. A couple of studies have shown that if you're catching it after it goes to production, it costs you like thousands of times more than actually catching it during development time. So ultimately, most tools are actually focusing to try to get it as early as possible. So the developers not only identify them as they create the problem,
正确。所以最终，信念是是的，你在开发周期中越早捕捉到它，它就越便宜。我认为存在指数级增长。几项研究表明，如果你在它进入生产环境后才捕捉到它，它的成本比在开发期间捕捉到它要高出数千倍。所以最终，大多数工具实际上都在专注于尝试尽可能早地获取它。所以开发者不仅在他们制造问题时识别它们，
but they actually can learn from the solution because it is fresh in your mind. You say, oh, there is a problem here. Oh, that actually makes sense. Or if you have a symbolic head that even can help you with the explanation, then's even easier for uh uh for the developer to figure out oh yeah that is the problem makes sense i know how to fix it and you're pretty much never going to make that mistake again which is the beauty of it all yeah that makes sense it's so true if you if you have
而且他们实际上可以从解决方案中学习，因为它在你的脑海中是新鲜的。你说，哦，这里有一个问题。哦，那确实有道理。或者如果你有一个符号头，甚至可以帮你解释，那么开发者就更容易弄清楚“哦，是的，这就是问题所在，有道理，我知道怎么修复它”，而且你几乎永远不会再犯那个错误，这就是它的美妙之处。是的，这很有道理，确实如此。如果你
to fix something especially if you're under the gun because it's affecting production and maybe it's two months after you wrote it, you're probably not going to retain anything meaningful. And then you could just make the same mistake again later. Yeah. Or it's very likely that somebody else had to fix it, not the original developer. Oh, that's true too.
必须修复某些东西，特别是如果你在压力下，因为它影响了生产，而且可能是在你写完它两个月后，你可能不会保留任何有意义的东西。然后你以后可能会再犯同样的错误。是的。或者很有可能其他人不得不修复它，而不是最初的开发者。哦，那也是真的。
Yeah. So what is the, you know, in your entire career of being an engineer, leading teams, leading projects here and abroad or depending on where you're listening, abroad and then in Europe, what's the
是的。那么，在你作为工程师、领导团队、在国内外领导项目的整个职业生涯中，或者取决于你在哪里收听，在国外然后在欧洲，什么是
biggest, most intense horror story? What's the bug that really kept everyone up at night? Something that terrified you? That's a fair question. I mean, as a good example, actually, it literally kept us up at night.
最大、最强烈的恐怖故事？那个真正让每个人彻夜难眠的 Bug 是什么？让你感到恐惧的事情？这是一个公平的问题。我的意思是，作为一个很好的例子，实际上，它确实让我们彻夜难眠。
We had, this is back in the early days of Vistaprint. It was the holiday season. It was like pretty much like 10 times more volume than a standard day, right? And you have to process millions of orders. So like production went down, like literally, and that's very costly because a huge amount of orders that pretty much cannot go through.
我们有，这是在 Vistaprint 的早期。那是假期季节。它基本上是标准日 10 倍的流量，对吧？你必须处理数百万个订单。所以生产环境宕机了，真的，这非常昂贵，因为大量的订单基本上无法通过。
So we actually had like, yeah, pages went up, like we had to wake up like three in the morning plus, and then we went to the office, and I think we spent something like two to three days because what happened is that we actually overflowed one of our our production facilities so they could not really take any more orders. So we really had to create the fake production facilities in a matter of like a day. And we didn't know exactly originally where the problem is. It took us some time to actually figure it out.
所以我们实际上有，是的，寻呼机响了，我们必须在凌晨三点多醒来，然后我们去了办公室，我想我们花了大约两到三天，因为发生的事情是我们实际上淹没了我们的一个生产设施，所以他们真的无法再接受任何订单了。所以我们真的必须在一天之内创建假的生产设施。我们最初并不确切知道问题出在哪里。我们花了一些时间才真正弄清楚。
And then we said, OK, that's a really serious problem. And then we have to continue fixing it. And the fix was pretty bad because we had to make a new production facility uh so we spent a couple of days in the office non-stop it was a quite interesting experience and uh we ate a lot of pizza i'm sure you built some camaraderie and i'm sure you uh never want to do it again that is for sure yes yes i mean there was a of SQL back then. We had to write a lot of SQL migration scripts to catch that. And even today, that is not the most bulletproof language to do things in. Yeah. I mean, I think, so Patrick, it'd be cool to hear from you too.
然后我们说，好的，那是一个非常严重的问题。然后我们必须继续修复它。修复过程非常糟糕，因为我们必须建立一个新的生产设施，所以我们在办公室不间断地待了几天，这是一次非常有趣的经历，而且我们吃了很多披萨。我敢肯定你们建立了一些情谊，而且我敢肯定你们再也不想那样做了。那是肯定的，是的，是的。我的意思是，那时有 SQL。我们必须编写大量的 SQL 迁移脚本来捕捉它。即使在今天，那也不是做事情最万无一失的语言。是的。我的意思是，我想，所以 Patrick，听听你的故事也会很酷。
But I have a couple. One, we were working with this vendor who is providing basically an internal tool for us. But the internal tool, this is a terrible design decision, the internal tool is using the same fleet of machines as our production site. And basically they deployed the internal tool and about a month later the entire site went down and we were trying to figure out what it was it was really hard to sort of find
但我有几个。一个，我们正在与这个供应商合作，他们基本上为我们提供一个内部工具。但内部工具，这是一个糟糕的设计决定，内部工具使用的是与我们生产站点相同的机器集群。基本上他们部署了内部工具，大约一个月后整个站点宕机了，我们试图弄清楚它是什么，这真的很难进行
do some root cause analysis and what we ended up finding was this one file where, so folks out there might know in C++ if you append to a string and you do this many, many times, it's actually not a big deal. Because C++ will just allocate a big chunk of memory and then start filling it up slowly. But in other languages, and I think this was in Visual Basic, every time you append to a string, it makes a copy of the string. I think Java does this
做一些根本原因分析，我们最终发现的是这一个文件，所以外面的朋友可能知道在 C++ 中如果你追加到一个字符串并且你这样做很多很多次，这实际上没什么大不了的。因为 C++ 会分配一大块内存，然后开始慢慢填满它。但在其他语言中，我想这是在 Visual Basic 中，每次你追加到一个字符串时，它都会复制该字符串。我想 Java 也会这样做
too. It makes a copy of the string that's big enough for the two strings you're trying to stick together and then puts both of them there. And so this entire file was just thousands and thousands of append string, append string, append string commands. And, you know, the logic was all fine. So, you know, logically, it was doing the right thing. And if you for a while, it didn't matter. But then the memory fragmentation just eventually causes all the machines to start underperforming. And then they, it's one of these things where once something is start slowing down, more requests come in, people just start hitting refresh, which then causes it to slow down and blows up. And I just remember spending just so many hours, same thing, just eating pizza.
。它会复制一个足够大的字符串，容纳你试图粘在一起的两个字符串，然后把它们都放在那里。所以整个文件只是成千上万个追加字符串、追加字符串、追加字符串的命令。而且，你知道，逻辑上都是好的。所以，你知道，逻辑上，它在做正确的事情。而且有一段时间，这并不重要。但后来内存碎片最终导致所有机器开始性能下降。然后它们，这是那种一旦某事开始变慢，更多请求进来，人们就开始点击刷新，这反过来导致它变慢并爆炸的事情之一。我只记得花了这么多时间，同样的事情，只是吃披萨。
I think we worked almost like 30 hours straight. We were sleeping in the office. And then finally we figured out it was this internal tool. And then we just deleted it and went home. Nice. Yeah. internal tool and then we just deleted it and went home nice yeah yeah i don't know that i have any like horror stories where i just stay up 30 hours that i guess that sounds pretentious not trying to be i mean tons of bugs like you mentioned i mean we have one where we were dereferencing a pointer that wasn't set correctly in c++ and of course you get data, it was just sort of garbage data. But it, you know,
我想我们连续工作了将近 30 个小时。我们在办公室睡觉。然后最终我们弄清楚是这个内部工具。然后我们就删除了它，回家了。不错。是的。内部工具，然后我们就删除了它，回家了。不错。是的，是的，我不知道我是否有任何像我彻夜工作 30 小时的恐怖故事，这听起来很自负，不是想那样。我的意思是，像你提到的那样有大量的 Bug，我的意思是，我们有一个在 C++ 中取消引用一个没有正确设置的指针，当然你得到了数据，那只是一些垃圾数据。但它，你知道，
mostly worked until it didn't. So it was mostly zeros. And then occasionally, it would not be zeros and would break stuff. And we it was very hard to debug because, you know, 99% of the time, it would work correctly, because you would dereference an address that was just set to zeros. But then occasionally, it would dereference an address that would have something else in it, that would be some old, not overwritten data, and then the program would crash. Yeah, I remember. This is a classic.
大部分时间都能工作，直到它不能工作。所以它大部分是零。然后偶尔，它不会是零，会破坏东西。我们很难调试，因为，你知道，99% 的时间，它都能正常工作，因为你会取消引用一个刚好被设置为零的地址。但偶尔，它会取消引用一个包含其他东西的地址，那会是一些旧的、未被覆盖的数据，然后程序就会崩溃。是的，我记得。这是一个经典。
Yeah, I remember similar things, just like after two hours of runtime, it would just randomly crash. It always comes out something like that. I think actually the hardest things for me lately are just issues with the data. And these are things where I think there's a lot of tooling that still needs to be built. So, I mean, one example I'm thinking of is someone made a bug in a system where they had a day and they needed to convert it to day of week.
是的，我记得类似的事情，就像运行两个小时后，它会随机崩溃。它总是以类似的方式出现。我认为最近对我来说最困难的事情只是数据问题。这些事情我认为还有很多工具需要构建。所以，我的意思是，我正在想的一个例子是，有人在系统中制造了一个 Bug，他们有一个日期，他们需要将其转换为星期几。
And somehow they messed that up. And so there was no Sunday. So basically all the Sundays were set to Saturday. And so there was twice as many Saturdays as you'd expect, no Sundays. And that just caused total havoc in all of the downstream systems. But again, it's not something you can find pretty easily. It's something kind of inherent in the data. Yeah, that's actually one of the most common errors
不知何故他们搞砸了。所以没有星期天。基本上所有的星期天都被设置为星期六。所以星期六的数量是预期的两倍，没有星期天。这在所有下游系统中造成了彻底的混乱。但同样，这不是你可以很容易发现的东西。它是某种数据中固有的东西。是的，那实际上是最常见的错误之一
that we reported in 2019. It's a date time formatting. Just there's like hundreds of different ways to actually make a mistake in those and obviously hard to figure out. And that's why we have a whole category of issues that actually detects that which is pretty cool yeah totally yeah i think uh um anytime you can stay to utc time it's probably just stay in utc just don't print the date unless
我们在 2019 年报告的。它是日期时间格式。只是有数百种不同的方式来犯错，显然很难弄清楚。这就是为什么我们有一整类问题实际上可以检测到这一点，这很酷。是的，完全同意。是的，我想，任何时候你能保持 UTC 时间，可能就保持 UTC，除非
maybe at the very end um am pm is another big issue in that space i think i've had myself a couple of issues like this, that you say, okay, it's daytime, and you forget that you're actually using the 12 hours only, and then you actually don't keep track of AM, PM at all. Yeah, yeah. We have an issue where I think there's something about there's an extra hour.
可能在最后，AM PM 是那个领域中的另一个大问题，我想我自己也有过几个这样的问题，你说，好的，它是日期时间，你忘记了你实际上只使用 12 小时，然后你实际上根本不追踪 AM、PM。是的，是的。我们有一个问题，我想关于有一个额外的小时。
I don't remember the details, but we have an anomaly. Oh, that's right, yeah. That's but we have an anomaly. So we have an anomaly detection system, and to this day, every twice a year when there's a daylight savings shift, there's more or less traffic than we expect that day, and an alarm goes off.
我不记得细节了，但我们有一个异常。哦，对了，是的。那是，但我们有一个异常。所以我们有一个异常检测系统，直到今天，每年两次夏令时转换时，那天的流量比我们预期的多或少，警报就会响起。
Cool. Sorry, go ahead. I was going to say, with daylight savings, we always get uh sorry go ahead i was gonna say with daylight savings we always had issues that uh during that week there was always you're gonna show up to a meeting and half of the people will not be there just because they're in a different time zone that's in a different daylight savings that's always uh always a funny one yeah totally yeah that's i i'm waiting for the day where they get rid of that i i personally I like it to be lighter later. And so there was actually, they were going to, over here in California, they were going to pass a we should get rid of it but then in typical politicians way they said but each country decides how they want to implement it so now each country decides if they want to use it or not so it's uh still gonna have some countries drag along
酷。抱歉，请继续。我本来想说，关于夏令时，我们总是得到，抱歉，请继续，我本来想说关于夏令时，我们总是遇到问题，在那一周，你总是会出现在会议上，有一半的人不会在那里，仅仅因为他们在不同的时区，处于不同的夏令时，那总是，总是很有趣。是的，完全同意。是的，我正在等待他们摆脱它的那一天。我个人，我喜欢它晚一点亮。所以实际上，他们打算，在加利福尼亚这里，他们打算通过一个我们应该摆脱它的法案，但后来以典型的政客方式，他们说但每个国家决定他们想如何实施它，所以现在每个国家决定他们是否想使用它，所以它仍然会有一些国家拖延。
oh geez hey guys i'm gonna jump in for a minute here with a word from this episode's sponsor. We're happy again to have educative.io, an online learning resource. And since the last time we came to you talking about them, they've changed things up a little. They have a brand new option. Instead of buying courses one by one and selecting what you want, they now offer, they still offer that, but they also offer the ability to get a subscription where you can, for the length of your subscription, access any of the courses. So all the same courses we talked about before, you can now access for sort of a flat monthly or per time period fee. And because of their sponsorship, they've agreed to give us at educative.io
哦，天哪。嘿，伙计们，我要插话一分钟，说几句本期赞助商的话。我们很高兴再次邀请到 educative.io，一个在线学习资源。自从我们上次向你们介绍他们以来，他们做了一些改变。他们有一个全新的选择。与其一门一门地购买课程并选择你想要的，他们现在提供，他们仍然提供那个，但他们也提供订阅的能力，你可以，在你的订阅期间，访问任何课程。所以我们之前谈到的所有相同的课程，你现在可以以某种固定的月费或按时间段付费的方式访问。而且因为他们的赞助，他们同意给我们 educative.io
slash programming throwdown 10 off either a single month's purchase or the subscription that's right you get 10 off pretty much anything in the store so so i was looking at the courses after we talked last time and um a things that I guess I missed and which is one is they have a number of courses that are actually just completely free if you want to try them so they have free previews you know little parts of many of their courses but they also have a number of languages from scratch so C++ and Python from scratch and those courses are actually free so not only are they a great way to learn
slash programming throwdown 10% 的折扣，无论是单月购买还是订阅，没错，你可以在商店里几乎任何东西上获得 10% 的折扣。所以，我在我们上次谈话后查看了课程，嗯，我错过的一些事情，其中之一是他们有许多课程实际上是完全免费的，如果你想尝试的话，所以他们有免费预览，你知道，他们许多课程的小部分，但他们也有许多从零开始的语言，所以 C++ 和 Python 从零开始，这些课程实际上是免费的，所以它们不仅是学习的好方法
or advance your knowledge in those languages, but it's a great way to actually check out the platform first because spending any money, I mean, I don't like spending money. So not spending money and still being able to check something out always alleviates a little bit of the sort of nervousness around doing it.
或提升你在这些语言中的知识，而且这是实际先查看平台的好方法，因为花钱，我的意思是，我不喜欢花钱。所以不花钱仍然能够查看某些东西总是减轻了围绕做这件事的一点紧张感。
And this is a great way to check out the platform, these from scratch courses. And there's also another course I found on here that's the practicing for programming interviews. So Jason, you do interviews at your company. Do you recommend people practice programming before they show up to your interview? Yeah, totally. The cool thing about this is, when you're kind of writing in this sort of environment, they kind of give you some setup and then you write some code and then you can even kind of validate
这是查看平台的好方法，这些从零开始的课程。而且这里还有我找到的另一门课程，是练习编程面试。所以 Jason，你在你的公司进行面试。你建议人们在出现在你的面试之前练习编程吗？是的，完全同意。这个东西很酷的地方在于，当你在这种环境中写作时，他们会给你一些设置，然后你写一些代码，然后你甚至可以验证
that you've done the right thing. And that kind of loop of writing something, especially in this case, unless you're sort of using an editor and then coming back, but if you're writing it in the editor, you're kind of writing that as if you're writing it on a whiteboard. And then you're getting this instant feedback like, OK, you got it right. You need to try again.
你做了正确的事情。那种写作的循环，特别是在这种情况下，除非你正在使用编辑器然后回来，但如果你在编辑器中写作，你就像在白板上写作一样在写作。然后你得到这种即时反馈，比如，OK，你做对了。你需要再试一次。
And that's really going to kind of give you that muscle memory that you need so that when you go to a whiteboard interview, you kind of are a little bit more prepared. I think the from scratch courses are really solid. And the other part of it is, you know, it's it's a different way to learn. You know, there might be some folks out there who can do sort of the lecture thing. For me, it's it's it never really resonated with me. Something like this where it's hands on is really good for people like me. And it's awesome that they have this free course. So even if you're, you know, a Python guru, um, but, but you think this might be a good way to learn something else, uh, you know, you could dive through the Python course. You can pick a different language and dive through that, uh, totally for free. And then if that looks like the kind of,
这真的会给你提供所需的肌肉记忆，这样当你去参加白板面试时，你会准备得更充分一些。我认为“从零开始”的课程非常扎实。另一方面，这是一种不同的学习方式。有些人可能适合听讲座，但对我来说，这种方式从来没有引起过共鸣。像这样动手实践的课程非常适合我。他们提供这门免费课程真是太棒了。所以即使你是一个 Python 大神，但如果你认为这是学习其他东西的好方法，你可以深入学习 Python 课程，或者选择一门不同的语言并深入学习，完全免费。如果这看起来是你喜欢的学习模式，
you know, learning model, that's really going to work for you. Um, you know, that you kind of know that without having to spend any money. They didn't really. I was trying to think about it. I guess when I was learning a program, I mostly did it from like books before even really like getting on the Internet or there being Internet. I mean, I guess there probably was, but we didn't really use it. So the closest I could think of this was did you ever do Vim tutor? No, I didn't oh so if you ever you know have accessed vim one of the things that will reckon are i guess vi is the same thing i'm not really good about the difference between the two um so if you either if you open them sometimes the bottom would be like i forget there's some command you can type and it will
那么你无需花费任何金钱就能知道它是否适合你。我当时在想，我学习编程时，在真正上网或互联网普及之前，我主要是通过书本学习的。我想当时可能已经有互联网了，但我们并没有真正使用它。我能想到的最接近的例子是，你用过 Vim tutor 吗？没有，我没用过。哦，如果你曾经使用过 Vim，你会发现——我想 vi 也是一样的，我不太清楚两者的区别——如果你打开它们，有时底部会显示，我忘了是什么命令了，你可以输入它，然后它会
basically walk you through like a document which also tells you like how to edit and you like move up and down in the document and it's sort of almost like kind of like interactive fiction about learning how to use vim oh yeah emacs has something similar oh okay and i was thinking like actually this kind of is like that but you know of course like 100 times better or whatever but yeah you know when you originally said that i thought you were thinking about um they actually used to have these um i keep wanting to say choose your own adventure they're about the same form factor as those choose your own adventure books but it's not you read it you know left to right um but but you get to a point and there's basically like a little puzzle and um um you know you're supposed to like solve the puzzle and then somehow there's basically like a little puzzle. And, you know, you're supposed to like solve the puzzle.
基本上引导你阅读一份文档，它会告诉你如何编辑，以及如何在文档中上下移动，这几乎就像是关于学习如何使用 Vim 的互动小说。哦，是的，Emacs 也有类似的东西。哦，好的，我当时想这实际上有点像那样，当然比那个好上一百倍之类的。但当你最初提到这一点时，我以为你在想……他们过去确实有这些……我一直想说“选择你自己的冒险”，它们的形式和那些“选择你自己的冒险”书籍差不多，但不是让你从左到右阅读，而是当你读到一个点时，基本上会有一个小谜题，你需要解决这个谜题，然后以某种方式……基本上就像一个小谜题。而且，你知道，你应该去解决这个谜题。
And then somehow there's some way to like validate you got it right. And then you keep reading. And so the idea is you have to, it's kind of on the honor system. But you would be reading, this is just like a paperback book. And then it would be like, oh, put in this basic code. And then edit it to solve the puzzle. And that's basically how i got started yeah so i mean i think this you know format is you know obviously catching on in a lot of different
然后以某种方式验证你是否做对了。然后你继续阅读。所以这个想法是，你必须依靠诚信系统。你阅读的时候，这就像一本平装书。然后它会说，哦，输入这段基础代码。然后编辑它来解决谜题。这基本上就是我入门的方式。是的，所以我的意思是，我认为这种格式显然在很多不同的地方流行起来，
places and it's really awesome to see um this is a learning resource i think it'll really resonate with people the ability to be able to be almost anywhere and be able to interactively you know read write the code not necessarily just like listening to a lecture and trying to figure out like how do i make it go 50 faster or how fast can i go before i can't understand the person anymore uh not that i've ever done that before um but yeah i think this is a great forum for learning yeah this is awesome guys check it out educative.io slash programming throwdown that's going to get you a 10 discount that's also going to let them know that um you know that that that uh this was a good slot for them that that they were a good sponsor for us so so it
看到这一点真的很棒。我认为这是一种学习资源，它会引起人们的共鸣。能够随时随地以互动方式阅读和编写代码，而不必仅仅是听讲座，试图弄清楚“我该如何让它快 50%”或者“我能听多快而不至于听不懂对方在说什么”——并不是说我以前做过那种事——但我认为这是一个很好的学习论坛。是的，这太棒了，伙计们，去看看 educative.io/programmingthrowdown，这会给你 10% 的折扣，也会让他们知道这是一个很好的推广位，他们是我们很好的赞助商，所以这
helps us out um it also helps helps you out and uh check it out also let us know you know send us comments send us email uh let us know what you think of the courses and you know we can relay that back to the folks at educative andative and give them feedback so they can keep improving. All right. Thanks for the sponsorship. And let's get back to interviewing. All right. I want to talk more about how DeepCode works.
对我们有帮助，对你也有帮助。去看看吧，也请告诉我们你的想法，给我们发评论、发邮件，让我们知道你对这些课程的看法，我们可以把这些反馈转达给 Educative 的伙伴们，让他们不断改进。好的，感谢赞助。让我们回到面试环节。好的，我想更多地谈谈 DeepCode 是如何工作的。
We talked about from the technical side. But as a developer, what's sort of that experience like? So there's multiple ways to use deep code that's the idea is we have a public api and you can command line interface you can really hook it up anywhere you want but the most standard usage as we spoke earlier is part of the ide so we released already a vs code and atom plugins so you can directly just get the suggestions as you as you code the next stage is obviously after you commit the code and we actually have integrations with uh with github bitbucket and gitlab uh where we have a bot that automatically will comment on pull requests that will tell you hey you guys doing these new things by the way
我们谈到了技术层面。但作为一名开发者，那种体验是怎样的？使用 DeepCode 有多种方式，我们的想法是提供一个公共 API，你可以使用命令行界面，随心所欲地连接它。但正如我们之前所说，最标准的使用方式是作为 IDE 的一部分。我们已经发布了 VS Code 和 Atom 插件，这样你可以在编写代码时直接获得建议。下一个阶段显然是在你提交代码之后，我们实际上与 GitHub、Bitbucket 和 GitLab 进行了集成，我们有一个机器人会自动在拉取请求（Pull Request）上发表评论，告诉你：嘿，你们在做这些新事情，顺便说一下，
you're introducing this issue please look at it so So in this case, it gives you a diff analysis on the new things. Obviously, at the latest stage, you can actually add it to any CI or CD pipelines or QA, let's put it that way. So it really depends on the workflow that you're actually working in, but you can use it pretty much anywhere. That makes sense. So from a usability standpoint standpoint it sounds similar to other static analysis tools like like
你引入了这个问题，请看一看。所以在这个案例中，它会为你提供关于新内容的差异分析（diff analysis）。显然，在后期阶段，你可以将其添加到任何 CI/CD 流水线或 QA 中，可以这么说。所以这确实取决于你实际工作的流程，但你几乎可以在任何地方使用它。这很有道理。所以从可用性的角度来看，它听起来类似于其他静态分析工具，比如
Shellshock or or Pylint or Flake or one of these things. I mean yeah from the workflow perspective absolutely the case the big difference is that we actually run pretty much in real time so we actually complete the analysis in like seconds like one second for average piece of code to even less. So that allows you to actually have the IDE piece because a lot of linters, et cetera, when they run the ID, it takes time to actually get results. So speed is one of our main focus.
Shellshock、Pylint、Flake 或类似的东西。我的意思是，从工作流程的角度来看，绝对是这样。最大的区别在于我们实际上几乎是实时运行的，所以我们实际上在几秒钟内完成分析，平均一段代码甚至不到一秒。这使你能够拥有 IDE 的功能，因为许多 linter 等工具在 IDE 中运行时，获取结果需要时间。所以速度是我们关注的重点之一。
Everything has to be real time for the experience to be correct and for the people not to say, okay, I have to wait now for 15 minutes to get my results. Hopefully, I get an e-mail. Great. The amount of time you save is wasted by waiting. Yeah. Are you running some machine learning in the Visual Studio Code extension, or are you making an RPC with the code to a server?
一切都必须是实时的，这样体验才是正确的，人们才不会说：“好吧，我现在得等 15 分钟才能得到结果。希望我能收到一封电子邮件。”太棒了。你节省的时间都被等待浪费了。是的。你在 Visual Studio Code 扩展中运行机器学习吗，还是你通过代码向服务器发起 RPC 调用？
Yeah, it's a server-side analysis. So pretty much we have a cloud server that can do that. For larger companies, you can also have the on-premise server that actually runs it locally if you're fully behind a firewall, for example. Got it. Okay, that makes sense. So if you, and we'll talk about this, actually we should talk about the pricing and all that later, but if you're a student or you're working on a hobby project,
是的，这是服务器端分析。我们有一个云服务器可以做到这一点。对于大型公司，如果你完全在防火墙后面，也可以拥有在本地运行的内部服务器。明白了。好的，这很有道理。所以如果你——我们稍后会谈到定价之类的问题——但如果你是一名学生，或者你正在做一个业余项目，
then you just turn this on, you're good to go. If you're working at, you know, if you're working at like a military research lab or something, then maybe, you know, it might not be the best idea to turn this on. And so what you want to do is reach out to Boris and get a contract for your company and get something on premises. That is correct.
那么你只需打开它，就可以开始使用了。如果你是在军事研究实验室之类的地方工作，那么也许打开它可能不是最好的主意。所以你想做的是联系 Boris，为你的公司签订一份合同，并获得本地部署版本。没错。
And then when you install it in the IDE, you can just select which server you actually want to get the analysis happening on, either the cloud-based, SaaS, or your own. Cool, that makes sense. And so what languages are supported? Is it pretty much everything or are you starting with a few key languages?
当你把它安装在 IDE 中时，你可以选择你想要在哪个服务器上进行分析，是基于云的 SaaS，还是你自己的服务器。酷，这很有道理。那么支持哪些语言？是几乎所有语言，还是你从几种关键语言开始？
So we started with kind of the top languages. So we have Java, JavaScript, TypeScript, Python. So this is live today. This month we're going to release C and C++, very likely. Hey, hey, hey, good news. CHRIS BROADFOOTENHEIMER- News of all. ANDREAS SUIKAITISONISI- And yeah, we're going to be adding a couple more languages this year. Pretty much our main focus has been to kind of perfect, making sure that we really rock on all languages that are live,
我们从顶尖语言开始。所以我们有 Java、JavaScript、TypeScript、Python。这些今天就可以使用。这个月我们很可能会发布 C 和 C++。嘿，嘿，嘿，好消息。而且是的，今年我们将增加更多语言。我们主要的重点是完善现有语言，确保我们在所有已上线的语言上表现出色，
rather than just add every single language out there and be just average. And we built the platform that architects should do. So also now adding new languages is extremely fast for us, which will enable the addition of new languages as well. Plus, at some point, there is the vision to open source it so people coming up with new languages, which happens a lot these days, can just add it as well.
而不是仅仅添加每一种语言却表现平平。我们构建的平台架构就是为了做到这一点。所以现在添加新语言对我们来说非常快，这也将使新语言的添加成为可能。此外，在某个时候，我们的愿景是将其开源，这样人们开发出的新语言（如今这种情况经常发生）也可以直接添加进来。
Cool, that makes sense. So anything that's machine learning-based, you have to sort of deal with this sort of four possible outcomes, right? You know, so true positive means, you know, a person made a mistake they've seen a thousand times. You tell them about it. They fix it. That's awesome. True negative is, you know, everything else that your program is not telling people about or you know things that are fine right um but let's talk a little bit about the false situation so you know if you're if your program tells someone to fix something but then they kind of disagree what's sort of what do they do there
酷，这很有道理。所以任何基于机器学习的东西，你都必须处理这四种可能的结果，对吧？你知道，真阳性（True Positive）意味着一个人犯了一个他们见过一千次的错误。你告诉他们，他们修复了它。这太棒了。真阴性（True Negative）是你的程序没有告诉人们的其他所有事情，或者你知道那些没问题的事情。但让我们谈谈错误的情况，如果你的程序告诉某人修复某事，但他们不同意，他们会怎么做？
is there a way to give you feedback in the ide or do they turn that one off is there like a uh you know slash slash slash ignore or something that they can put? Absolutely, so yeah, we definitely have slash slash deep code ignore or this ignore, which will pretty much ignore the specific instance in the line before or after. And you can actually highlight
有没有办法在 IDE 中给你反馈，或者他们是否关闭了那个功能？有没有类似“// deepcode ignore”之类的东西可以输入？当然，我们绝对有“// deepcode ignore”或类似功能，它会忽略前一行或后一行中的特定实例。你实际上可以高亮显示
which specific issue ignoring because sometimes you can have more than one on a single line of code. And same thing, you can actually provide feedback. So the way our platform is built that once you provide a feedback we can very quickly i'm talking within minutes we can actually adjust the knowledge base and either kind of expand the rule or split it into multiple rules so it actually get accurate so that's uh that's the beauty of the platform that you can very quickly and very easily ingest those this user feedback and kind of really push the fix to everybody else immediately. Cool. That's so awesome.
要忽略哪个具体问题，因为有时一行代码中可能会有多个问题。同样，你也可以提供反馈。我们的平台构建方式是，一旦你提供反馈，我们可以在几分钟内非常迅速地调整知识库，要么扩展规则，要么将其拆分为多个规则，使其变得准确。这就是平台的魅力所在，你可以非常快速且轻松地吸收这些用户反馈，并立即将修复方案推送给其他人。酷。这太棒了。
How are the errors surfaced? So can you kind of walk me through that? So the machine learning system says this, I guess, syntax flow tree, we've seen this pattern before and we don't like it. How does that turn into something actionable in sort of an English format where someone can read that and grok it? So this is one of the kind of nice add-on engine that we have, which gives you kind of semantic explanations of the problem. This is where the symbolic ai comes in uh so as we have metadata to the original piece of the code we can kind of
错误是如何呈现的？你能带我了解一下吗？机器学习系统说这个，我想是语法流树，我们以前见过这种模式，我们不喜欢它。这怎么变成一种人类可读的英语格式，让人们能够阅读并理解它？这是我们拥有的不错的附加引擎之一，它为你提供问题的语义解释。这就是符号人工智能（Symbolic AI）发挥作用的地方。当我们为原始代码片段添加元数据时，我们可以
define gaps and say hey the function that you're calling and we kind of tell you which function if you actually hover with the mouse over it will actually show you the line of code and the function that you are calling right is getting user input right and you can actually see what the object with the user input is and this input flows into some kind of an execution on the back end for example and we can actually when you cover it we'll show you where it is and we can tell you hey this user input is not being sanitized by by the time it gets to the execution uh which can actually cause some kind of a denial of service or path traversal or many different undesirable things executing on your backend.
定义差距并说：嘿，你调用的函数——如果你用鼠标悬停在上面，我们会告诉你哪个函数——实际上会向你显示代码行，而你调用的函数正在获取用户输入。你可以看到用户输入的对象是什么，这个输入会流入后端执行的某种流程中。例如，当你悬停时，我们会向你展示它在哪里，我们可以告诉你：嘿，这个用户输入在到达执行点时没有被清理，这实际上可能导致某种拒绝服务攻击、路径遍历或在你的后端执行许多其他不可预见的事情。
But that's the idea. So we actually have a human-readable explanation that semantically points to each object of the problem. And you can use a code base to point you through it so you can actually walk it through and understand the flow. So am I right to say there's sort of this machine learning step where you are doing this almost unsupervised problem of looking at GitHub PRs and trying to find patterns of mistakes, right?
但这就是想法。所以我们确实有一个人类可读的解释，在语义上指向问题的每个对象。你可以使用代码库来引导你完成它，这样你就可以实际走一遍并理解流程。那么我说得对吗，有一个机器学习步骤，你正在进行这种几乎是无监督的问题，查看 GitHub PR 并试图找到错误模式，对吧？
But then to convert that into some sort of like slot-based language generation, there has to be like a person in the loop there, right? So is there someone on your side who's looking at the most common errors and then trying to find a symbolic representation of that? Yeah, so we have a semi-supervised learning on this second part,
但要将其转换为某种基于槽位的语言生成，必须有人参与其中，对吧？所以你们那边是否有人在查看最常见的错误，然后试图找到它的符号表示？是的，我们在第二部分进行了半监督学习，
which allows us to create categories of the problems right so we have a data flow category for example saying hey you have a user input and flows into something and it's not sanitized so what happens here we define this category uh and then with a very small seat of examples right um our machine learning actually identifies thousands of objects that are actually doing the same thing. So we have, you provide three examples, so 10, 20 examples of user input functions. And then our core automatically says, hey, there's actually here 6,000 different user inputs that I found. So that becomes your category with 6,000 potential user inputs, right? Then you
这使我们能够创建问题类别。例如，我们有一个数据流类别，说：嘿，你有用户输入并流入某处，但没有被清理。所以这里发生了什么？我们定义了这个类别，然后用非常少量的示例，我们的机器学习实际上识别出了数千个正在做同样事情的对象。所以你提供三个示例，或者 10 到 20 个用户输入函数的示例。然后我们的核心会自动说：嘿，我在这里发现了 6,000 种不同的用户输入。所以这就变成了拥有 6,000 个潜在用户输入的类别。然后你
actually say, what are the things or where something actually can get executed on the backend, and that becomes the category of those problems. And then you look for sanitizers, and you can have like thousands of, or hundreds of thousands of sanitizers. And any combination of those three can actually lead to a data flow problem, right? So with very little effort from a user,
实际上说，哪些东西或哪里可以在后端执行，这就变成了这些问题的类别。然后你寻找清理器（sanitizers），你可以有成千上万或数十万个清理器。这三者的任何组合实际上都可能导致数据流问题。所以用户只需付出很少的努力，
you end up having with pretty much millions of combinations of problems that you detect. And this is kind of the benefit that you don't have to write individual rules. Instead of writing a million rules, within five minutes, you actually created a category that actually represents millions of potential problems. Oh, that's super interesting. So I think it sounds a little similar to sort of these lookalike, you know, fingerprint models that they do for spam detection. So, for example, someone will mark an email as spam. And so then what will happen is a system will add that to a list of seed spam emails. And then afterwards, there's some lookalike system that says, does this new email share a lot of the same properties as my spam email? If so, then let's sort of add it to the spam category.
你最终就会拥有数百万种可以检测到的问题组合。这就是好处，你不必编写单独的规则。你不需要编写一百万条规则，在五分钟内，你就创建了一个代表数百万个潜在问题的类别。哦，这太有趣了。所以听起来有点像垃圾邮件检测中使用的那种“相似”指纹模型。例如，有人会将一封电子邮件标记为垃圾邮件。然后系统会将其添加到种子垃圾邮件列表中。之后，有一个相似系统会说：这封新邮件是否与我的垃圾邮件共享许多相同的属性？如果是，那么让我们将其添加到垃圾邮件类别中。
And so it's almost like an active learning type thing. So in your case, someone says, hey, you know this, or from the GitHub pull request, you can emerge that this passing the string directly in this function was not, you know, sanitary. And so here's a pull request that adds a sanitization wrapper around the string. And you can seed sort of, let's say, a new problem with that,
所以这几乎是一种主动学习。在你的案例中，有人说：嘿，你知道这个，或者从 GitHub 拉取请求中，你可以推断出直接将字符串传递给这个函数是不卫生的。所以这里有一个拉取请求，在字符串周围添加了一个清理包装器。你可以用这些示例来播种一个新问题，
with a few of those examples, and then do some lookalike type thing to find, as you said, like all of the adjacent pull requests that are most similar in nature to that one. And then if that process gave you pretty high signal, so there wasn't a lot of false positives, then you say this is sort of like a good concept. And then you can roll that out. Yeah.
然后做一些类似的事情来找到，正如你所说的，所有在本质上与那个最相似的相邻拉取请求。如果那个过程给了你很高的信号，没有太多的误报，那么你就说这是一个很好的概念。然后你可以将其推广。是的。
And the add-on point to this is that while you create a category, since we have the knowledge base and the history of Git in memory, let's put it that way, it automatically tells you how many people have fixed such problems, how many people are vulnerable to this problem today, and you get this real time pretty much. So as you kind of create a category, you automatically see, is that an important category? And you can even look into the vulnerabilities and say, okay, am I seeing any false positives or not? So you can very quickly check if it's accurate category
补充一点，当你创建一个类别时，因为我们有知识库和 Git 的历史记录在内存中，它可以自动告诉你多少人修复过此类问题，今天有多少人容易受到这个问题的影响，你几乎可以实时获得这些信息。所以当你创建一个类别时，你会自动看到：这是一个重要的类别吗？你甚至可以查看漏洞并说：好的，我是否看到了任何误报？所以你可以非常快速地检查它是否是一个准确的类别，
and it should be pushed to production. That allows, again, within 10 minutes, you can actually create millions of rules compared to what a current rule-based system looks like. Very cool. So can you tell me a little bit about the scale on the machine learning side? Like you're ingesting just an
并且应该推送到生产环境。这再次允许你在 10 分钟内创建数百万条规则，而目前的基于规则的系统则无法做到。非常酷。那么你能告诉我一些关于机器学习方面的规模吗？听起来你正在摄取
unbelievable it sounds like you're just an unbelievable amount of of data um do you have sort of like web mirrors running 24 7 scraping github i mean is this something that runs on thousands and thousands of machines in the cloud um um give me an idea roughly of the scale and the scope of this effort so that's the beauty of it all we have built very lean pipelines and we don't have to scrape we've obviously read GitHub once but once you actually receive the repository history
令人难以置信的数据量。你们是否有 24/7 全天候运行的网络镜像在抓取 GitHub？我的意思是，这是在云端成千上万台机器上运行的东西吗？给我一个关于这个工作规模和范围的大致概念。这就是它的魅力所在，我们构建了非常精简的流水线，我们不必抓取。我们显然读过一次 GitHub，但一旦你收到了存储库历史记录，
and convert it into our internal representation which is considerably smaller than the GitHub representation then you actually just have to look at the new changes into this repository internal representation, which is considerably smaller than the GitHub representation, then you actually just have to look at the new changes into this repository. So we don't have to kind of re-grab everything else, right? And then our internal representation is pretty efficient. So we're talking, let's say, for all of Java, you're going to be talking like a couple of terabytes.
并将其转换为我们的内部表示，这比 GitHub 的表示要小得多，那么你实际上只需要查看这个存储库内部表示中的新更改，这比 GitHub 的表示要小得多，那么你实际上只需要查看这个存储库中的新更改。所以我们不必重新获取其他所有内容。而且我们的内部表示非常高效。所以我们谈论的是，假设对于所有的 Java 代码，你谈论的是几个 TB。
It's not going to be much larger than that. And analyzing, let's say, all the Java codes out there, it will take you less than a day. Everything happens quick in a run. Wow, so less than a terabyte for all Java code on GitHub. Yeah, and this is not only the tip, this is all the history. What we do, we pretty much use in memory,
不会比这大多少。分析所有的 Java 代码，不到一天就能完成。一切都在运行中快速发生。哇，所以 GitHub 上所有的 Java 代码不到一 TB。是的，这不仅是最新版本，这是所有的历史记录。我们所做的是，我们几乎使用内存，
we have a memory index, a semantic index of every single version of every single repository out there in GitHub. For a pre-language, obviously, we do it. Wow, that's amazing. I mean, that's just a treasure trove of information. That's what you need in order to actually extract the knowledge of the development community automatically, right? Otherwise, if that's not efficient and if you cannot index it and grab it really fast, then you're kind of dead in the automatically, right? Otherwise, if that's not efficient and if you cannot index it and grab it really fast, then you're kind of dead in the water, right? It would take, like, months to actually figure anything else.
我们有一个内存索引，一个 GitHub 上每个存储库每个版本的语义索引。对于每种语言，我们显然都这样做。哇，这太神奇了。我的意思是，那简直是一个信息宝库。这就是你为了自动提取开发社区的知识所需要的，对吧？否则，如果效率不高，如果你不能索引它并快速抓取它，那么你就死定了，对吧？那需要几个月的时间才能弄清楚任何事情。
Yeah. That's one of the reasons why we chose not to do static analysis without requiring to build or compile anything because clearly if you want to compile something from, like, five years ago, like, it's unlikely you'll be able to actually build it on your own.
是的。这就是我们选择不进行静态分析而不要求构建或编译任何东西的原因之一，因为显然如果你想编译五年前的东西，你不太可能在自己这边构建它。
Yeah. Yeah. And then the time too, to build all of that code is extraordinary. Cool. So tell me a little bit about, well, first of all,
是的。而且构建所有这些代码的时间也非常惊人。酷。那么告诉我一些关于……首先，
so folks who are listening, who are, you know, in college and high school, or they're working on open source projects, what is available for them? and what's the price like? Everything for free is the short answer. So we are 100% free for anything open source.
对于正在听节目的大学生、高中生，或者正在从事开源项目的人，他们可以使用什么？价格是多少？简短的回答是全部免费。所以我们对任何开源项目都是 100% 免费的。
Our motto is pretty much, hey, we are learning from the open source community, pretty much everything. We want to actually encourage the open source community to get better, be more dynamic, because we'll learn even more. So it's fully free. So anything in the Cloud, GitLab, Bitbucket, GitHub, it's free. You just log in with your account for the Git and all your repositories you can scan,
我们的座右铭几乎是：嘿，我们正在从开源社区学习几乎所有东西。我们想鼓励开源社区变得更好、更具活力，因为我们会学到更多。所以它是完全免费的。因此，云端、GitLab、Bitbucket、GitHub 上的任何东西都是免费的。你只需用你的 Git 账户登录，你所有的存储库都可以扫描，
you can scan anything open source. For educational purposes, the same. We've actually worked with a couple of universities already, even some of them are developing open source add-ons, which is great as part of their master thesis. Nice. And I think the first one that started doing that was San Jose State University. So we're very happy with the collaboration there. And it is free for them because that's the idea.
你可以扫描任何开源项目。出于教育目的，也是一样。我们已经与几所大学合作，甚至其中一些正在开发开源插件，这作为他们硕士论文的一部分非常棒。不错。我想第一个开始这样做的学校是圣何塞州立大学。所以我们对那里的合作非常满意。这对他们来说是免费的，因为这就是我们的想法。
We believe that students, they start using things and over time, as they go into the industry, they say, hey, I actually need that commercially. And our tool is pretty good for people that are learning things. That's the main thing
我们相信学生们开始使用这些东西，随着时间的推移，当他们进入行业时，他们会说：嘿，我确实在商业上需要它。我们的工具对于正在学习的人来说非常不错。这是最主要的事情，
because we explain the problems, we provide examples how other people have fixed it in a totally different settings. So it's a great learning tool as well. And actually, we're also free for small companies like if you have less than 30 developers pretty much
因为我们解释了问题，我们提供了其他人如何在完全不同的设置中修复它的示例。所以它也是一个很好的学习工具。实际上，对于像如果你有不到 30 名开发人员的小公司，我们也是免费的，
you can just start using it and nobody will ever bother you Cool, this is awesome we've been super fortunate to have you on the show, have Zenhub on the show and a few other folks on the show CircleCI on the show and almost all of these
你可以直接开始使用，没人会打扰你。酷，这太棒了。我们非常有幸请到你来节目，请到 Zenhub 和其他一些人来节目，请到 CircleCI 来节目，几乎所有这些产品对学生都是免费的。所以如果你正在做一个高级设计项目，你是一名 CS 学生或计算机工程学生，你有一个高级设计项目，从头到尾需要三、四、五个月。所以这不是一个琐碎的项目。你和一个团队一起工作。你可以有持续集成。你可以有一些项目管理。而且你可以完全免费地使用 DeepCode 静态分析。
actually every one of these products is free for students. So if you're doing, let's say, a senior design project, you're a CS student or a computer engineering student, you have a senior design project, and it's something that's going to take you three, four, or five months from start to finish. So it's not a trivial project. You're working with a team. You could have continuous integration. You can have some project management. And you can have the deep code static analysis totally for free.
这真的会给学生们一种在团队、在行业中工作的感觉，这真的很棒。这就是为什么我让学生们更容易进入软件开发领域，因为所有的工具都能帮助他们变得更快。是的，完全同意。我相信这是个性化的，但从高层来看，它对企业是如何运作的？
And it's really going to give you students out there a feel of what it's like to work on a team, an industry, which is really amazing. That's why I allow students to get into software development much easier these days, because all the tooling helps them be faster. Yeah, totally. I'm sure this is personalized, but just at a high level, how does it work for businesses?
假设有人在一家规模超过 30 人的企业工作，但不是那种巨大的企业集团。所以他们在一家中型企业工作，比如梅西百货之类的。他们该如何获得 DeepCode
Let's say someone works at, not a, let's say, bigger than a 30-person business, but not a huge, giant conglomerate. So they work in, say, a mid-sized business, Macy's or something, as an example. How can they go about getting deep code
本地部署版本？那看起来是什么样的？本地部署是通过 Docker 容器实现的。所以你得到你的自定义 Docker 容器。设置大约需要 10 到 15 分钟。然后你就有了自己的 DeepCode 本地服务器。
on-premises? And what does that kind of look like? So the on-premise stuff, it happens through Docker container. So you get your custom Docker container. It takes about 10 to 15 minutes to set up. And then you have your own deep code on-premise server.
然后你拥有与 SaaS 选项完全相同的集成和完全相同的优势。那里的成本根据你的规模而定，我想说每位开发人员每月 30 到 50 美元。显然，我们提供 30 天免费试用，这样人们可以在购买前体验它，用他们的代码库进行测试，看看它是什么。所以那里也有一个无风险试用。酷。是的，这很有道理。现在我们来谈谈公司。DeepCode 是在苏黎世联邦理工学院（ETH Zurich）成立的吗？公司总部在那里吗？是的，我们距离苏黎世联邦理工学院主校区只有五分钟路程。
And then you have the exact same integration, the exact same benefits than the SaaS option. And the cost there is ranging depending on your size, I would say between $30 to $50 per developer per month. Clearly, we offer a 30-day free trial so people can experience it, test it with their code base, see what it is before they have to purchase. So there is a risk-free trial there as well. Cool. Yeah, that makes sense. So now we'll jump into a little bit about the company. So is DeepCode in, you mentioned ETH Zurich, is DeepCode based out of there, the company? Yeah, we are literally five minutes away from the Zurich ETH main campus.
所以我们是一家苏黎世公司。酷，是的，我以前去过那里。如果我没记错的话，那里非常贵。但很美。是的，我曾经去那里参加过一次会议。是的，我可能会说错。你可以纠正我。但我记得我买了一个汉堡，大概是 8 美元左右。
So we are a Zurich-based company. Cool, yeah, I've been there before. It's very expensive, if I remember correctly. But it's beautiful. Yeah, I went there for a conference one time. And yeah, I'm probably going to get this wrong. You can correct me. But I think I just got a hamburger and it was like $8 or something.
那听起来像是一个便宜的汉堡。好的，是的，可能不止那个价格。但这可能是 10 年前的事了。但是的，苏黎世很美。我记得我们坐火车去了，我想说是伯尔尼，但已经很久了。某个地方，我们去滑雪了，非常华丽。嗯，伯尔尼是首都，所以你很可能去了别的地方滑雪。哦，好的，好的。我想也许我们有一天去了伯尔尼，然后另一天……哦，实际上是的，我们去了少女峰（Jungfraujoch）。
That sounds like a cheap hamburger. Okay, yeah, it's probably more than that. But this was probably like 10 years ago. But yeah, Zurich is beautiful. I remember we took the train to, I want to say Bern, but it's been a long time. Some place and we did some skiing and it was it was gorgeous well burn is the capital so likely you went to somewhere else for skiing oh okay okay i think maybe we did burn one day and then another day oh actually yeah we went to young far yuck
就像它是最高点，少女峰。是的，是的，大厅，好的，就是那样。然后我想在那附近，有这个……我唯一记得的是它是高山滑雪，但它是一种非常自然的下坡。它就在这座山上，一直延伸下去。非常华丽。是的，这里有很多滑雪选择。是的，阿尔卑斯山有很多不同的，比如场外滑雪、场内滑雪，而且确实非常自然。
like it's the tallest point young frau hall yeah yeah Hall, okay, there we go. And then I think somewhere around there, there was this, all I really remember is it was a downhill skiing, but it was kind of a very natural downhill. And it was literally down this mountain, and it just kind of kept going and going. It was gorgeous. Yeah, there's so many skiing options here. And yes, the Alps are like, yeah, so many different, like off-piste, non-piste, and long-piste, and very natural indeed.
是的，太棒了。所以每个人都在那里。如果人们对那里的工作感兴趣。目前没有远程工作之类的吗？我们确实有两个人正在做远程工作，但这主要是当你从事集成工作时，比如我们实际交付的开源项目。大部分核心工作几乎都在这里发生。因为它非常动态，变化太快，很难进行跨时区的协调。显然，随着时间的推移，这会扩展，这样我们就可以有特定的领域可以在线下完成，但今天有太多的谈话互动
Yeah, it's awesome. So everyone's over there. So folks are interested in jobs that would be over there. There's not like remote work or anything like that at the moment? We do have two people that are doing remote work, but mostly this is when you're working on kind of the integrations, like open source things that we actually deliver. Most of the core is pretty much happening here. Because it is very dynamic, it's changing so fast that it's very hard to do the coordination over time clearly that will expand so we can have specific areas that could be uh worked on offline but today there's too much talking interactions
与团队沟通，所以是的，我们喜欢彼此靠近。公司现在有多大？我们有 15 人，并且在不断增长，正如我所说，现在我们大约每个月增加一个新人。哇，是的，所以它很好，而且在增长，因为这个原因非常令人兴奋。是的，哇，我的意思是，你明年几乎会翻倍。是的，我们去年翻了一倍，但这正是初创公司的定义，如果你没有至少 100% 的同比增长，那么你就不再被视为初创公司了。所以你必须这样做。这是真的。是的。好吧，如今这令人难以置信。
with the team so yeah we like to be close to each other how big is the company right now we're 15 people continuously growing as as i said now we're getting roughly about one new person per month uh wow yeah so it's uh it's it's nice and and growing and very exciting because of that yeah wow i mean so you'll you'll almost double next year yes and we did double last year but that's kind of that's the definition of a startup like if you don't do like 100 percent at least year over year then you're not considered a startup anymore. So you have to. That's true. Yeah. Well, nowadays it's unbelievable.
实际上，你最近看到了很多 IPO。但看起来好像没有人会 IPO。所以就像，好的，这家公司价值 600 亿美元。它真的是一家初创公司吗？我的意思是，拜托。是的，完全正确。是的。那么如果人们想在夏天去那里实习，现在太早了吗，还是你们在做实习？我们所做的是，我们做很多
Actually, you're seeing a lot of IPOs nowadays, like very recently. But it seemed as though no one was going to IPO. And so it's like, okay, this company is worth $60 billion. Is it really a startup? I mean, come on. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So what about internships if folks want to come there for a summer is it kind of too early for that or do you are you doing internships so what we do we do a lot of
硕士论文，我们通常一次至少运行三个。他们大多数来自 ETH，但我们也有一些学生来自其他学校，他们正式成为 ETH 的一部分，只是为了硕士论文，他们实际上做到了。所以如果人们想专门做与我们所做相关的研究，绝对有选择，通常是在我们的平台之上，因为这能带来很多有趣的话题。所以我们做了很多这样的事情。酷。酷。这很有道理。至于技能，听起来你肯定在寻找做程序分析的人。
master master student thesis is here we usually run at least three at a time most of them are from ETH but we've gotten some students that are coming from another school that officially become part of ETH just for the master thesis and they actually do it. So there are definitely options if people want to do research specifically that's related to what we do and usually on top of our platform because that enables quite a lot of interesting topics. So we do a lot of those. Cool. Cool. That makes sense. So as far as skills, it sounds like you're looking for definitely people who do program analysis.
此外，听起来也许一些图卷积或深度学习的人会有用。我们有一些深度学习，是的。这是为了我们正在准备的一些新服务。它一直在发生，所以我们这里有许多 GPU 在运行并发出噪音。好的。酷。但是，是的，程序分析，大部分后端显然是用 C++ 编写的。但是，是的，核心开发人员也是，前端也是。
Also, it sounds like maybe some graph convolution or like some deep learning folks would be useful. We have some deep learning, yes. It's for some of the new services that we're preparing for. It's been happening, so we've had a number of GPUs here running and making noise. All right. Cool. But, yes, so program analysis, most of the back end is in C++, obviously. But, yeah, pretty much core developers as well, front end as well.
我们有一个非常强大的团队，所以那里总是有机会。酷，在 DeepCode 工作是什么感觉？那么有什么让 DeepCode 作为工作场所独一无二的东西吗？哦，好吧，这绝对是一种令人振奋的体验。你可以把它想象成一边喝消防栓里的水一边冲刺。
We have a pretty strong team, so there's always opportunities there as well, front end as well. We have a pretty strong team, so there's always opportunities there as well. Cool, and what's it like to work at DeepCode? So what is something that kind of makes DeepCode unique as far as a place to work? Oh, well, it's definitely an exhilarating experience. You can think about it as sprinting while drinking from a fire hose.
所以是的，每天都有新事情发生。你甚至无法轻易地计划你的一天，因为有新事情。所以内部，团队动力十足，而且是该领域令人惊叹的专家。他们不断创新新的解决方案和方法，这些方法往往连研究人员都要花几年时间才能取得成功。所以很多事情我们甚至没有时间再发表了，
So yeah, there's daily new things happening. You cannot even plan your day easily enough because there's new things. So internally, again, the team is highly motivated and then kind of amazing experts in the space. And they keep on innovating new solutions and methods that oftentimes even researchers actually spend years on without much success. So a lot of those things we don't even have time to publish anymore,
但这是必须的。从外部角度来看，再次看到所有大公司或开源框架都在使用我们，这感觉很好。我的意思是，这几乎就是让我们深夜工作的原因，以及开发人员自发地说：嘿，这太棒了。我喜欢这个。
but it is required. And then from an external perspective, again, like seeing all the major companies or open source frameworks using us, it's pretty nice. I mean, this is pretty much what keeps us working late at night, as well as having developers kind of unpromptedly saying, hey, that's amazing. I love this.
你们正在构建一些了不起的东西。所以是的，这让它变得非常有趣。酷。这太棒了。是的，我敢打赌刚开始时很紧张，因为你必须弄清楚你所处的市场规模。
You're building something amazing. So that's yeah, that makes it lots of fun. Cool. That's awesome. Yeah, I bet it's intense in the beginning because you don't, you have to figure out really like the size of the market you're in.
所以我有一个朋友几年前创办了一家公司。他说这只是巨大的起起落落。这是一辆过山车火箭飞船，你只是被扔得到处都是。是的。但这很棒，因为你真的很喜欢前沿的东西。我们与苏黎世联邦理工学院密切合作，所以那里有很多研究成果，新事物不断涌现，这太棒了。那太棒了。你有没有想过……嗯，我前几天收到了一些东西
And so I have a friend who started a company a couple of years back. And he says it's just huge ups and downs. It's this rollercoaster rocket ship where you're just getting thrown all over the place. Yeah. But it's amazing because you really like cutting edge stuff. We work very closely with dth zurich so there's a lot of research coming from there and new things come up all the time which is great that's awesome have you thought about um you know i got something the other day
来自 GitHub，说我很久以前开源的这些旧项目之一有一些安全漏洞。它实际上是在项目的依赖项中。所以 GitHub 给我也发了电子邮件。大约一周后，GitHub 实际上给我发了一个拉取请求，更新了那个依赖项。你有没有想过基本上你可以做一种类似出站营销的方法，你只是 ping GitHub 上的随机人并说，你的代码有这个错误，你可以修复它，你知道？所以我们做了一些小测试，比如我们实际上在 Mozilla 和其他一些地方提交了拉取请求，
from github saying this one of these old projects that that i open sourced a long time ago um has some security vulnerability. It was actually in a dependency of the project. And so GitHub emailed me. And then about a week later, GitHub actually sent me a pull request updating that dependency. Have you thought about basically you could do almost like an outbound marketing approach where you just ping random people on GitHub and say, your code has this error, you can fix it, you know? So we've done small tests, like we've actually filed pull requests in Mozilla and some other places,
特别是在安全领域，这显然受到高度重视，几乎所有的互动项目都被接受了。所以是的，我们测试过它，我们确实也在考虑使其更具可扩展性。非常酷。这听起来太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我肯定会尝试这个。所以实际上，一个问题。如果有人安装了扩展程序，在我的笔记本电脑上，我为了好玩在随机的东西上做了一堆黑客攻击，但我也有一个真正的工作。
specifically in the security space, that's obviously well regarded, and pretty much all of the interactive projects were accepted. So yes, we've tested it, and we are indeed looking into making it more scalable as well. Very cool. That sounds totally awesome. Yeah, I mean, I'm definitely going to try this. So actually, one question. If someone installs the extension, so on my laptop, I do a bunch of hacking on random things for fun, but I also have a real day job
特别是在安全领域，这显然备受推崇，而且几乎所有的交互式项目都被接受了。所以是的，我们已经测试过了，而且我们确实也在研究如何使其更具可扩展性。太酷了。听起来棒极了。是的，我的意思是，我肯定会尝试一下。那么实际上，有一个问题。如果有人安装了这个扩展程序，比如在我的笔记本电脑上，我为了好玩会随意折腾各种东西，但我也有正经的工作
where they don't want the source code going out of the off premises, right? So how can I sort of reconcile that with this extension? Can I, is there an easy way to turn it on and off? Should I have two copies of Visual Studio Code? How would I do that? So that's a common request by our users. So what happens for each project that you open,
如果他们不希望源代码离开办公场所，对吧？那么我该如何将这一点与这个扩展程序协调起来呢？有没有一种简单的方法可以开启或关闭它？我是否应该拥有两个版本的 Visual Studio Code？我该怎么做？这是我们用户的一个常见需求。所以，当你打开每个项目时，会发生什么呢？
you actually get a pop up saying, are you okay for this code to be transmitted and analyzed? And you can clearly say no for the project you don't care about. I got it. So really, any project, so when you first install it, you have three open projects, you're going to get three separate pop ups for each one saying, do you want to do this? Do you want to do this? Do you want to do this?
实际上你会收到一个弹窗，询问你是否同意传输并分析这段代码。对于你不关心的项目，你可以明确选择拒绝。我明白了。所以，当你第一次安装它时，如果你打开了三个项目，你会收到三个独立的弹窗，分别询问你是否要这样做？是否要这样做？是否要这样做？
Same thing if you close and open a new one, you're going to it again because that's yeah common common concern and uh it has to be fresh in your mind you have to always make the decision saying do you want to do it or not uh you can always clearly disable it fully if you know that like i'm going to be working only on my proprietary stuff for uh for a day yeah that makes sense very cool yeah i will check this out i think patrick's gonna have to wait until you make the C++ version. Actually, yeah, now you're doing Java, right? Or is it still C++? No, mostly C++ still.
如果你关闭并打开一个新项目，情况也是一样的，你又会再次收到询问，因为这是一个非常普遍的担忧。你必须时刻保持警惕，必须始终做出决定，确认是否要执行。如果你知道自己这一整天只会处理私有代码，你当然可以完全禁用它。是的，这很有道理，太棒了。我会去试试看。我想 Patrick 得等到你们推出 C++ 版本才行。其实，你们现在是在做 Java，对吧？还是说仍然是 C++？不，大部分还是 C++。
Oh, is it? Okay. Got it. So Patrick, I'll ping you later this month. All right. Wow, it does move fast. Wow, that's quick. Cool.
哦，是吗？好的，明白了。Patrick，我这个月晚些时候会联系你。好的。哇，进展真快。哇，这太快了。酷。
So tell people how they can reach out to you. So these would be, you know, students, people who want to get this installed at their workplace. What's a good way to reach out to you? And then also, what's a good way separately for people just kind of passively follow what you're doing, maybe on social media or somewhere else yeah so reaching to me my personal email is boris at deepcode.ai uh you can also just go to deepcode.ai website there is a live chat there well not always live but if we are up and running you'll be live otherwise we'll come back to you over an email um uh on social media obviously our twitter handle is deepcodeai uh same for linkedin and i'd say with twitter and linkedin you'll be getting most of the news about us uh we also have a medium uh page where people can actually get our developer advocate actually pushes a lot of a lot of cool articles examples where it is like top bugs specific vulnerabilities vulnerabilities. So that's pretty nice. And now we actually have a YouTube channel for tutorials,
那么告诉大家如何联系你。比如学生，或者想在工作场所安装这个工具的人。联系你的好方法是什么？另外，对于那些只想被动关注你们动态的人，比如通过社交媒体或其他平台，有什么好方法吗？联系我的话，我的个人邮箱是 boris@deepcode.ai。你也可以直接访问 deepcode.ai 网站，那里有实时聊天功能，虽然不总是实时的，但如果我们在线，你会得到回复，否则我们会通过电子邮件回复你。在社交媒体上，我们的 Twitter 账号显然是 @deepcodeai，LinkedIn 也是一样。通过 Twitter 和 LinkedIn，你可以获得关于我们的大部分新闻。我们还有一个 Medium 页面，我们的开发者倡导者会在上面发布很多很棒的文章和示例，比如顶级漏洞或特定漏洞的分析。这非常不错。而且我们现在还有一个 YouTube 频道用于发布教程，
like how do you set up VS Code, for example, how do you use VS Code? How do you actually set up the on-premise versions as well? So all those you can have kind of a quick walkthrough. So it should answer most of your questions. Very, very cool. And you said, just to recap, there's a command line for folks who aren't using VS Code.
比如如何设置 VS Code，如何使用 VS Code？以及如何设置本地部署版本？所有这些你都可以通过快速指南来了解。它应该能回答你大部分的问题。非常非常酷。刚才总结一下，你提到对于不使用 VS Code 的人，还有一个命令行工具。
There's a command line option that they would install through app or something. That is correct. You can just use the command line, can literally point to a folder to analyze all the code there. Very cool. Thank you so much Boris. This is awesome. I personally am enriched by this. I'm going to try it out. I'm really excited to see what comes what comes up and let me know all right cool sounds good we really appreciate your time and yeah you folks at at home you should check this
有一个命令行选项，他们可以通过 apt 或类似工具安装。没错。你只需使用命令行，就可以直接指向一个文件夹来分析其中的所有代码。太酷了。非常感谢 Boris。这太棒了。我个人受益匪浅。我打算试用一下。我很期待看到结果，到时候再告诉你。好的，没问题，听起来不错。非常感谢你抽出时间。各位听众，你们也应该去看看这个工具，
out this sounds amazing if you're on your drive and you didn't catch uh some of the some of the the you know the urls and things like that we're going to post it all in the show notes. So you can just, from iTunes or whatever podcast app, you can just tap over to the description. There's a link to the show notes. You can get all the info from there. But thanks again, Boris. This is awesome.
这听起来太棒了。如果你正在开车，没能记下一些网址之类的信息，我们会把它们全部发布在节目说明中。所以你可以直接从 iTunes 或任何播客应用中点击进入描述，那里有节目说明的链接。你可以从那里获取所有信息。再次感谢你，Boris。这太棒了。
And have fun. Do some skiing. And we'll reach out to you after we've tried this out. Sounds good. Thank you very much, guys. Appreciate it. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license.
祝你玩得开心，去滑雪吧。等我们试用之后会再联系你。好的，没问题。非常感谢你们，伙计们。感激不尽。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，也可以进行重混或改编，但必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。